honored is GD lon Jean watches have 110
World's Fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other timepiece lon Jean the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the lawn Jean with no
watch company it's time for the
launching chronister a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour brought to you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a presentation of
the lawn gene which nor wats company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lon Jean
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the lawn gene Cronus cope
mister william bradford huie editor of
the American mercury and mr. Donald I
Rogers an editor of the New York Herald
Tribune our distinguished guest for this
evening is dr. Nicholas neurotic former
Hungarian Minister of Finance the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers dr. narat ease and sewer
minister of finance and Hungary before
the Communists took over and had spent
some time in Moscow and behind the Iron
Curtain as an official of hungry we'd
like to have you tell us some of the
intimate things you'll learn behind the
Iron Curtain and we'd like to have you
perhaps start our show by telling us
about the effectiveness of our own
propaganda program how effective for
instance is the voice of America the
great difficulty for every broadcast
which cuts from the free world is to
penetrate Russia and there are two great
walls iron walls to this penetration the
first is of a technical nature there is
a psychological one the technical nature
of course is that you have to know that
in the whole huge Russian Empire mayor
so they are not more than two million
radio sets which you could control or
which you can get any foreign broadcast
how many people 220 million people about
now and we won't ruin these radios i
don't think i have to tell you see that
there are the special cast of
high-ranking communist and even they can
get those foreign broadcasts the fact
that eighty percent of those are
carefully jammed by the Russian
government transmitters so here you have
a situation when the people itself is
desh to any voice coming from though and
all that we lack is an audience with for
The Voice of America well tour any
Western broadcast exactly and the other
is of course of a difficulty of
psychological nature to answer your
question mr. Rogers was also do lasagna
me to those no tool is even they could
lessen even if we would have 200 million
sets in of radio set in Russia the
Russian people would not understand what
we tell them because their mentality
their background their experiences and
education is completely different to
tell today Russian about the American
Way of life about our concepts of
freedom and democracy don't believe it's
exactly the same as if you would tell a
man who was born blind that what is the
difference between white blue and dark
blue thank you believe it they not only
they don't believe it they can't grasp
it well is there anything we can do then
since the voice is ineffective what
propaganda measures can we take well mr.
Rogers there was a very old and mighty
very good idea the idea of sending
balloons over there and those balloons
would drop leaflets and the people could
read those leaflets look at the pictures
this would naturally one step forward
but what I pointed out in this book of
mine wall that even this evidence
because due to the special
indoctrination of the Russian people
what they would appreciate would be the
quality of the paper and this would be
about all because they would think that
all the other are the messages of the
American Ministry of propaganda they
believe that such a nonsense exists in
other words the tangible
that I pay attention to exactly now this
is what I point out that those leaflets
should be accompanied by a shower of Qi
guests of dime store gadgets a razor
blades soap cigarettes chocolate bars or
shaving cream and many other things
these things I don't have and Russia
today partially they don't have them and
partially they have it in a much worse
quality that we have over here and now
naturally you must know that the
Kremlin's propaganda tells them that you
people here in America downtrodden
slaves of capitalism that you have no
shoes that you have no clothes that you
are hungry all the time now Imogen those
Russians picking up those superior
things which would shower down on them
from those free balloons and begin to
look at them to wash with this soap
which is so much better reception so to
go ahead and shave with this American
razor blade which is thousand times
better than this terrible Russian razor
blade you know what we could plant in
their minds is a doubt towards their own
government because when they would see
those miraculous gadgets they would
begin to doubt that everything what they
hear about America or aggressiveness our
capital is more exploitation they would
begin to see that it is alive we could
bring our truth to this very simple way
and combat with it the great life I mean
you're telling a starter that perhaps
the best way we can prove the
superiority of our culture is to show
them that we have a superior brand of
soap well it's very difficult to prove
them a superior brand of culture because
they were told that their new superior
brand of culture in the cabinet culture
is but if we show them our soap they
might doubt also about their superiority
of the things you think soap is a more
effective weapon than ideas and if you
would know mr. chewy how important soap
is in Russia today you could sell are
they interested in culture do they pay
any attention to the cultural things of
life they do pay great attention but
this is also played up in the present
communist
reviewssee they give the stallion prizes
for what they call culture but it is
only communist propaganda it's no
culture finally in deeply Oh dr. you of
course on Hungarian and hungary has many
American friends I'm sure that some of
our audience would like you to tell us
tonight if a great cultural city like
Budapest is likely to to be changed
drastically or perhaps to be destroyed
as a cultural center what a what's
happening to Budapest today under the
occupation I early witness first the
physical destruction of budapest by the
soviet troops and the Nadi's and then
today we have to witness naturally from
here from distance the cultural
destruction which I would call cultural
genocide it was going and now to kill in
our youth in our people the feeling of
nationalism the feeling of loving their
country because how are yous is brought
up today unfortunately it in the loft
for stahli in the alleged great teacher
of mankind and today the children are
taught of hating their parents of hating
religion of hating their home and to die
one day for the great leader this is
effective among the children well I am
sorry to tell you that we in fingery we
have shown in two elections under
Russian occupation that we do not fall
community the anti communist parties in
Hungary got eighty-three percent of the
boats in spite of the Russian pressure
the era determine the anti company
that's right but you see the children
they are stay of salt mines you know you
can mold the minds unfortunately you can
even bribe them and today they are
taught this way and this is the greatest
disaster for the future of any of those
i wouldn't say satellite but captive
you're saying sir that within a period
of a generation a nation like Hungary
can disappear as a cultural entity not
only the cultural entity but I am afraid
that it might disappear as a national
entity or perhaps even as a racial
entity we have suffered so many in
during a thousand years of history but
no one went down to the grassroots of
natural existence to the extent of the
Communist Soviet occupation does how
long does the way of the West hell would
you say to to rescue a nation like
Hungary you know it is very hard
difficult to answer this question
especially political exiles we are
always accused that we want you
Americans to fight our war so I mustn't
tell you how our people suffer but I can
tell you one thing that due to this
terribly effective Soviet educational
system if those countries could be
liberated today it would mean that the
eighty percent of the people would fight
tooth and nail the Russians you employ
at a time is not in our favor as we like
to believe in this sector I am sorry to
say time is working against the code of
the is that true and these other
satellite nations and Yugoslavia and
Czechoslovakia well you got la vere is
now a different brand of communism you
know Tito so agami there's no yoga and
not different at all from Stalin young
Communist about Tito ISM sir great many
Americans place some hope than Tito ism
now do you place hope than Tito ISM
Mardi Misbah sure if our people would be
given the choice to choose what they
want to they do not want any brand of
community should its tell union or tea
toys or whatever they want no communism
at all they want capitalism well they
want freedom first and then to decide
how they want to live that they
definitely are where brought up under a
system of free enterprise and individual
initiative we call it capitalism here
well know about this business of freedom
sir are you telling our audience that
there still is a large group of people
and hungry who value personal freedom
and who would be willing to fight for it
I am definitely convinced about it but
under the present circumstances when the
secret police has an incredible and
terrible grasp over every single
individual of course you couldn't expect
those people to do something actually
for their liberation and it would be
suicide and you're saying that perhaps
if we wait as long as 15 years that that
aspiration for for freedom and liberty
may disappear in large sectors of the
Western world it might disappear in the
sense that more and more of those young
people would be thought and would
believe the infallibility of the
selenium Lani nian doctrine well I'm
sure doctors now Roddy that audience is
very much appreciated this very
forthright statement of the conditions
that exist in Hungary and behind the
Iron Curtain today thank you very much
for being with us tonight sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn gene krona scofflaws mister william
bradford huie and mr. Donald I Rogers
our distinguished guest was dr. Nicholas
now Roddy former Hungarian Minister of
Finance